all right good morning
all right are there any preliminary
matters
no your honor two days in a
good row great all right mr jeff you can
take
your place in the stand please
all right you're ready for the jury yes
okay
uh
all right
good morning ladies and gentlemen all
right you can have a seat
and so just a reminder that you're still
under oath mr deb okay all right yes
thank you thank you all right
good morning mr depp
good morning
yesterday you told us a little bit about
the beginning of your relationship with
miss heard
when did miss herd's behavior towards
you begin to change
um
i believe as i said yesterday there was
a hint of something
with the um having to do with
the boots
coming off and breaking
routine
um
it
her
her attitude or her
the way that she would
um
begin
to
speak to me
um
i think things first thing started
coming up and it was
i was suddenly just
wrong
about everything um
if uh
i made a statement about something
that i had been familiar with for
example in
in my
work that i've
that i've been
chopping away at for a good 30 something
years
um
i was suddenly wrong
and
then beyond that
if you
try to
um
explain yourself and correct
um
the the problem the misunderstanding
it would then
begin to heighten
as
ms herg was
unable to be wrong
it just didn't happen she couldn't be
wrong
um
so these
little
digs
um
and uh
that would would commence with sort of
demeaning
name-calling
berated sort of to be made a fool of
um
and those would escalate
into
a full-scale
argument and in the beginning
as
one does
one sticks up for oneself in a
in a debate as it were or an argument
over something to try to prove the point
but when it escalates and then
it's hard to explain but the
the argument would start here
and then it would roll around
and become this circular
thing of its own so
you get back to the beginning
essentially of the argument now it's
heightened even more
but it's still circular and there's no
way in or out
if
if if there's a dialogue between two
people
um
both people need to speak
but there was no
there was no way to fit a world in
it was uh it was a
sort of a
rapid fire
sort of endless
parade of
insults and
uh
you know
looking at me like i was
a fool
and i i just couldn't i was i was
i was having difficulty in my
mind of course and in my heart
dealing
uh with that sort of
barrage
and part
part of that is i i just
i was confused as to
the fact that
whatever her age was at the time of
these various arguments she was
mid-20s to late 20s and into 30s um
i couldn't i couldn't understand how
i had
somehow
somehow gotten
arrived at where i'd arrived
from where i came from in the beginning
of my life
and worked for 30 plus years
doing these things
it was astounding
how wrong i was about everything
that i've experienced
um
within the movie and within the film
industry or within
it well in just life itself
no i i
i was sort of not allowed to be
right not allowed to have a voice
so at a certain point
when that when what enters your mind
is
you start to slowly realize that you are
in a relationship
with your mother
in a sense and i know that that sounds
perverse and uh
obtuse but but the
the fact is that
some people search
for
weaknesses in people
and
that is to say
sensitivities
and when you've told that person you're
your life
and what you've lived through
what you've been through
just
as happens in relationships um
the more that
became
ammunition
from his hurt
to um
to um
either verbally
uh
decimate me or
or to
send me
into a
kind of tailspin of confusion and
depression and
um
well
it's it's it's not a happy day
it's not a happy week it's not a happy
month when you're
constantly being told
how
wrong you are about this or that what an
idiot you are
um
or
or anything
it just uh it then it then increased
increasing it became
an endless um
it became an endless that endless circle
like
so as it escalated and continued to
escalate
i went
straight to
what i had learned as a
youth
which was to
remove myself from the situation
so that it couldn't continue
because there's only so much your ears
can hear
and never
forget
so i would remove myself from the
situation as i've done as a youth
as much as possible
um
because i i
i just
i certainly didn't believe that there
was any need
for these various subjects or arguments
to come up
and
and
travel the distance that they
did so very quickly
to ramp up so fast
um
it was like you were
pinned to a wall and had to
just listen to it and take it
um so i found the only way to find any
sort of piece
was to uh
try to walk away if if
she didn't allow me to walk away
um there were times when um
i would
i would just go and lock myself in
uh
you know the bathroom or anywhere that
she couldn't get into
and that that happened
constantly
over the years
what would happen when the fights would
escalate other than going and hiding in
the bathroom
i'm sorry what would happen
well if if if they continue to escalate
um
if i continue to to try to
um
present my
my version or my side of the story
um when you when you when you're
approached in in a um
in a kind of
um
well when you're approached with such uh
anger
and
hatred it seemed like
pure hatred
for me
um
if i stayed to argue that
eventually i was
sure that it was going to escalate into
violence and
oftentimes it did
at times it did
and when you say violence what are you
referring to specifically
um
misheard in her frustration and in her
rage and her anger she would
strike out she would
it could begin with a slap it could
begin with a
shove
it could begin with you know throwing a
tv remote at my head it could be
throwing a glass of wine in my face
but
all in all it was it was just a
it was a constant
there was there was a built-in list of
of um
as i said
my
personal experiences which i
gave to miss heard
those those things were
those those those facts were used
against me um
as as weapons
um
especially when it
you know when it came to my kids
um
so
yeah i i did
there was no need for it
it just there was no need for it
too many lines were crossed you could it
was you couldn't see the lines anymore
you mentioned that
miss heard would use information you
gave her against you like a weapon can
you explain that a little bit
um
i mean i have said this before in
various interviews but certainly in life
um
my
if i have one
ambition and ambition
for me
um
when you equate it with hollywood
has become a very
has become an ugly word
in a sense because ambition
ambition means i want to be famous at
any cost
i don't care what for i just want to be
famous
that's one thing that's one
uh
part of it
if you have hunger
or a need
or a drive
to
to present your work
um
that that to me is is uh
the the way to go about it fame has
nothing to do with it so
i
was more
i mean
basically
the only the only ambition that i've
ever had in my life
came
arrived the second that my
first child arrived
and in the second in the instant
which was
to be a good parent to be to be a great
father to be the best father i could
and um
there were several occasions where
miss heard would um
would tell me what a bad father i was
um
and that i
had no idea how to parent
um
and again it falls into the same
categories before i couldn't understand
how in
52 years or however old i was at the
time
how i could
be so wrong about
everything
i i i mean i one learns along the road
the result is
the result of the road
is not important it's it's the road
that's important
because we don't know exactly what any
what's going to happen in
10 years we don't know so the road is
what i pay attention to and
paying attention to
trying to spend as much time with my
children
as possible
even that even that
would uh
that could send miss hurt into a
monumental tailspin
um
where i could i could hardly
ever
go and see my kids and spend time with
my kids
because she
had to have me there at all times
for
her own
needs
and i i that was
something that
once you realize that that's happening
and then there are hassles between the
children
and
her
the situation
starts to get a little more
grim
and a little more dire
um
that i was not prepared to
take i would not hear
the words
you're a bad father you're a terrible
father
you're awful father
so
one can only take so much of that before
bits of your brain start to just
bits of your brain bits of your heart
begin to
the valve gets shut off
because you can't hear it anymore and
and you know that it's not true
[Music]
and you know that it's meant as a web
it's just to it's to slice you up it's
to bring you down it's to demean you
it's to bring you into a place where you
start to believe
that there's something wrong with you
and
there's plenty wrong
with me there's plenty wrong with
a lot of people
but in all of these
situations
my main goal
was to retreat
because i think in life
most important
is
pick your battles
if there's a battle to be fought that
it's
grave and important
then that must be dealt with but
small insults and
kind of
teenage of high school tactics
um
this
bullying if you will
was um becoming too much
to take
so why did you stay with ms heard given
this type of behavior
that's a very complicated
answer i i would
i can only say that i
stayed
through all that
i'm sure that it's somehow related to
my father
remaining stoic
as my mother
would
beat him to death
i'm sure it had a lot to do with having
been in a
beautiful
wonderful 14 15-year relationship with
vanessa the mother of my children
raising those kids was
there there was
i have no interest in being a
uh you know the words that they use that
i i dislike very much
um a celebrity
or an entertainer or
fame is a strange word because i could
never equate it with my
self i pumped gas i worked construction
i
i uh printed t-shirts i
dug in you know
i had many many jobs
before any of
this happened to me so
i've been able to live both sides of
that
life
of of of of life i i know
the the very lows
and i know the very highs
of um
of where my life has gone and i
it's not
i don't i don't
again
it would be
pure idiocy for me to sit up here uh
as a as an actor
who has been very very fortunate
uh over the years and i can only say
it's
it's luck in the sense that someone
hands you the ball in the beginning
and you run with it
and you
run as far as you can before you get
tackled
so i that's that's
what i've always done but what happens
is
the word when the word celebrity
or or
uh
you when you are a what do they call it
a
public
public figure that's what it is a
celebrity or a public figure
um
again
not complaining but there
are things that
that are very uncomfortable
and that is to say
that at that point anybody can say
anything they want to about you
and that's happened to me over
36 years or more
that uh
things can be printed in the newspaper
that are utterly false
this is even early on
so this is where
that that privilege i suppose that they
call the privilege of celebrity
that's that's where that um
sticks a knife in you
um
because it's one of those
that's one of those situations where
your arms are too short to box with god
you know
there are too many
of them
coming at you
um so that yes
i don't know what her motivations
were
if they were
if there was some species of jealousy or
or there was some species of
maybe just maybe just hatred i don't
know
um
but in any case
the elevation and the escalation of
these
of these
day-to-day arguments
were um
simply
unnecessary
it was
it was not to help the relationship it
did not help the relationship it wasn't
meant to help the relationship it was
meant to feed her
[Music]
need
for
conflict
she has a need for conflict which is a
need for violence
it erupts
out of nowhere and uh
what i learned the only thing i learned
to do with it is exactly what i did as a
child
retreat
just take a step back which i told her
we need to remove ourselves
from each other even for an hour a day
anything
because this this can't go on
no one can live like this you know but
why did i stay i stayed
i suppose because my father stayed
i suppose because i had been in that
relationship with vanessa
and that was lost
and
i didn't
i didn't want to
i didn't want to fail
i wanted to try to make it work i
thought maybe i could help her
i thought maybe i could
bring her around
because the
amber heard that i knew
for the first year year and a half
was not this was not this um
suddenly this
um
opponent
it wasn't
my girl it was
it was
she had become my opponent and
everything that i did
just didn't fit her
um
it wasn't she didn't accept it
so i stayed because of course i didn't
want to fail
i didn't want
i didn't want to hurt
anyone
especially
misheard i didn't want to
break her
heart i i remember very well
that when my father left and
my mother
um betty sue had
that first attempted suicide
that i woke up to
and that visual in my head
and that was a direct result of my
father's
leaving
ms hurt had spoken of
suicide on a couple of occasions so
that
also becomes
a factor
that's that's also something that
that always lives in the back of your
brain and uh you that you fear
because
when i would leave sometimes i mean well
many times when i would try to leave
she would
you know stop me at the elevator with
the security guards crying screaming
you know i can't live without you i'm
gonna you know i'm gonna die
but you had to get out
there there were even a couple of times
when i did escape and i got to my house
arrived at my house and sweets her
and then five minutes later she would
arrive
in in
the
i don't know what car she was driving at
the time but um
she would arrive in her nightgown
screaming in the
parking
lot in front of in front of my house
uh
screaming to high heavens it would be
four in the morning three in the morning
it was ludicrous i it was it was uh
it was out of control it was
uncontrollable
did there come a time when you and miss
heard started recording your um
arguments
yes
the
um
in fact it was it was uh
i was i was the first uh
person
of the two of us to
to uh record
conversations
and it was for this reason
she would she would we would have been
talking the night before or arguing the
night before
and she would say
something there would be these again
these
these demeaning
berating insults there would be these
these these jabs there would be
anything to make me feel small
and uh
and like nothing
so what i
thought was
i'm going to record the conversation and
i told her this
i'm gonna record i'm gonna get my phone
and i'm gonna record our conversation
because i want you to hear
what
you've said to me tomorrow
so you because she would deny
having said those things what are you
talking about you know it was
it was surreal she had completely denied
things she said directly to my face in a
heated and
volatile way and she denied it so i went
to and i said
i'm going to record
us
and
i did and we
recorded the conversation
which
when she was on tape to
the first time it wouldn't it escalated
a bit but she was
well it was clear that she was
performing for the tape
because it was being recorded
so
that was uh
another clue that
something was
slightly rotten in the state of denmark
as it were
what did miss heard say to you about you
recording the the conversations between
you and
her i mean initially she said sure go
ahead
did that ever change
no
then
she she um
then she started recording
but um
surreptitious
um
without
without saying without telling me that
she was recording something
which is
fine but not so fine if you if you know
what i mean
um
even in those tapes i don't i don't
there's
it never took me to a place where
i would um
go
switch into
some other
entity which is
as she has used the term monster
never switched to
violence
violence is unnecessary
um
why would you hit someone to
make them agree with you
i don't think it works
mr depp you mentioned the term
monster and i think we heard about that
in the opening statements what what does
the term monster mean to you
well the term
the term monster means to me
you know in the beginning
she had used a different
word
to explain the same thing
and she she
would use the word demon demons
that my demons were coming out
that she had noticed that
there was a great change in my
attitude or my
um
uh
aggressiveness aggressive nature or
she would would
say that the demons had come out and
they'd control me and that sort of thing
i don't remember exactly
how monster came out
but
that word
stuck and it stayed well
until this day
what i believe the monster was
in ms heard's mind was
her
intense
imperfection intense um his belief about
what monster meant in miss herd's mind
it's not relevant there's no foundation
let me ask a different question
the objection go ahead when you use the
term monster what were you referring to
in your conversations with miss hurt
when i used the term monster with miss
heard i was
placating
if i if
if she had referred
to
[Music]
me as being a monster
there was no way that i was going to sit
there and go through a 45 minute
argument about you know
you're a monster no i'm not you're a
monster no i'm not you're a monster i'm
not
it
it was it was an impossibility so
what do you do
you accept
her vernacular you accept what the word
that she uses
and then you use that word
to to
placate
her
so that it would
at least calm
part of the
part of the aggression it would
it would lessen the
attacks
you know so explaining the monster
was for me
um
[Music]
i mean she she she had told me many
times that the monster
was
only me
when i was
using
drugs and and alcohol
but it
even when i was uh
stone cold sober off of alcohol
and
substances aside from my meds
the term the monster was still there
when she
uh
accused be accused me of being
high on
cocaine or
um
you know drinking like a you know some
sort of
um
like drinking like like like i was a you
know some kind of
19th century sailor
it's uh
that that that was the word she clung to
to
describe
but um
it was in her mind
not mine
how did your relationship with misheard
affect your substance use
[Music]
well
for example
when we were on the road you know when
you're traveling from uh if you're on a
press tour
or if you're making a film and you're
staying in
hotels or this or that
um
i would always have to get different
where we would always have to book an
extra room
that i was able to escape to
so i didn't have to lock myself in
another bathroom
um
it breaks you down
it
the constant haranguing breaks you down
and
you know there's a part of you that says
listen if i must be accused of this
might as well just do it
but
it never exceeded
it never
my
substance abuse or use
the alcohol
that i
used or drank uh
was
again
purely
it's it's that little boy
who didn't want to hear
or didn't want to feel the pain
of his
mother turning him into some kind of
ball of insecurity and
pain
so
yes
i was more inspired by miss heard
to reach out
for a numbing agent
um
because of the
because of the constant uh
clashes because of the
there wasn't there i mean maybe a few
days here and there but there wasn't a
day that you'd wake up and
you'd expect something was gonna hit the
fan and
pretty much like clockwork it did
so yes i
i had to have something
to distance me
and distance my
my
heart
from those
verbal
attacks i i had to have something to
to be able to
maintain
me
and i'm afraid for
a while because of because of placation
because
i
didn't want to
rock the boat as it were
again you pick your battles
so
placation seemed
um the best route if i was unable to
escape her
clutches
how if at all did miss herds try to
support you in abstaining from the drugs
and alcohol as she requested
i mean verbally
uh
and she had been quite clear verbally as
as
and then been
pretty
bullish and brutish about
wanting me to
telling me that i needed to stop
drinking
but drinking
was basically drinking
wine
with her
um
and
i i
for some i suppose maybe from youth i
don't know but i i've always had
um
a pretty high tolerance for
alcohol for
especially it's not spirits you know um
i i had a pretty good tolerance for
alcohol substances and things of that
nature
but
there was no i had no i've worked with
i've worked with therapists
drug
counselors
who have
actually
said the words to me because i wanted to
know
i wanted to know
am i am i an alcoholic am i
an alcoholic
or is this just
the same thing that i did as a kid when
i took my mom's nerve pill
um
do i have a drinking problem
and
it essentially came down to this
do you have a drinking problem johnny
objection calls for hearsay
what the doctors told him
i'm not sure he's saying what the
doctors told him
i think that's what's about to be
testified too
if you can if you can make that clear i
guess
um
let me ask you a different question mr
deb um
let's let him object to another one
um
how often would miss her drink in your
presence
while you were in a relationship always
well
yeah uh
ms heard
drank
she took a shine to a very nice spanish
wine called vegas cecilia
she and all her friends did
um
and um
yeah the wine would would come out and
miss her could
very easily drink two bottles of wine
per night
well not a
not a problem
what i found strange was when i did
um
did
get sober from from the
well i was off the
um
the opiates that i had that i had been
addicted to prior prior to a year or so
before a couple years before
um
she asked me if i would stop drinking
to save the relationship of course
i stopped drinking
and
i always found it
odd that
in support of me not drinking
that she might
stop drinking
but she did not she continued
and i i didn't make a big deal about it
in fact i would
open her
i would open her wine i would pour her a
glass and
that went on for
many many months you know in my sobriety
like i said i think i was sober for
around 18 months
then
there was a time when i was asked to and
i've been
off off of alcohol and off of
drugs everything
except for the medication
um that i'm prescribed uh i went i had
to go to london to give
um a lifetime achievement award to a
dear old friend
who was an elderly man a great actor
called his name's christopher lee
and he was a dear friend
and i was surprised he was being
surprised by
my showing up on stage
i just flown in from the states and he
was sort of surprised by
me arriving
to give him this award
and christopher
um came up and accepted the award
and we walked
they brought us backstage to
a beautiful library
where we
uh
i was with christopher and his wife
and a waiter came up and had three
glasses of champagne
and
christopher handed one to his wife he
handed one to me
and then he had the other and there was
a photographer there
and
the glass came up to toast
and i and i just in my head i thought
it's just
champagne you know a little bit
tink
to toast christopher and his lifetime
achievement award and so i've had
a half a glass of champagne with
christopher lee and his wife
um after that
immediately after that awards ceremony
i went to pick up missouri and
take her to dinner
at a restaurant
and i told her
that i'd had a half a glass of champagne
with
christopher
and i thought listen
it's
it's not like you know you're sitting in
a pub guzzling
pints of snake bites or guinness were
doing shots of jagermeister or
it wasn't even
at that point it wasn't even for
need to
bury
feelings or emotions it was literally
a joyous occasion for christopher and i
said to her
i i
i enjoyed it you know it gave me the
opportunity to enjoy
the
the actual
champagne the the the drink
and
the and my appreciation for wine and
wine making and that i've been
fascinated with for years and years
and i saw nothing wrong in it and i said
i'd like to have a glass of champagne
as she was sitting there with a
glass of wine
and
she we were in the restaurant and she
absolutely
lost it and got up and
stormed to the ladies room
and i told my security
and driver i said uh i think we have to
go
i'm gonna have to leave
so we left the restaurant and
went home and the mere suggestion of me
sipping a glass of champagne or having
one glass or two glasses of wine
she she went apoplectic she she she
it was uh
i was weak
uh
uh i was a complete mess i was an
alcoholic
i was you know i was gonna uh ruin
everything
my k you know your kids
your kids are not proud of you they they
can't stand what you're doing to
yourself
so at that point i said to her okay
listen
how about this you wanna you want to
support me not drinking
i've never asked you this before
how about you
stop drinking
how about you get sobriety
and share this sobriety with me
to support me and help me through this
what did she say to that no
no
she said no
she said she didn't have a problem
but i
i've never had a physical addiction to
alcohol
i don't
how often have you seen ms heard use
other illicit drugs in your presence
several
several times
and what drugs were those
um
what
she was always quite fond of mdma which
is which is ecstasy
um
and uh
mushrooms
um and
she had some
medications that she she she was on
already
that were
well one in particular is quite a high
velocity
um
speed if you will
call to
i don't know if i can say the name am i
allowed to say the name
it doesn't matter that's not necessary
um
what um
how often did you see miss heard
take mdma
well
a dozen times
20 times i you know
over the course of the year during the
course of the years
what about um mushrooms
um
mushrooms a little less mushrooms
probably
six
seven times
mr depp do you recall at the beginning
of her opening uh miss herd's counsel
mentioned that the first time you
supposedly struck miss heard was in
response to a comment about one of your
tattoos
yes
i remember and what is your response to
that
it
it didn't it didn't happen i
i've never struck miss hurt
as i said yesterday i've never struck
mister
um
i have never struck a woman
in my life
um
i'm certainly not
going to strike
a woman
if
she decides to make fun of a tattoo that
i
have on my body that's like
going into someone's journal and
picking out
uh
things you don't like
she had made mention
there was no incident of of of
argument when she when
the tattoo thing has been had been
brought up many many times and
there's really nothing i can do my i've
always thought of
my body as a
as a journal
if you will to to to mark experiences to
mark life experiences
it's you know for example when you're
when my first child was born i i had her
name tattooed
um
on my over my heart
which is where her little head used to
be when i
rock her to sleep
um i i marked my boy's birth by uh
tattooing myself
for him
so um
no one can go back or no one should go
back and rewrite their journals
why would i take such great offense
to someone making fun of a tattoo
on my body it uh
that that that allegation never made any
sense to me whatsoever
are there any tattoos that you had that
miss heard had an issue with to your
understanding
um
well the um
what a tattoo
[Music]
that i believe is up here
which used to say uh winona forever who
was a former girlfriend
and um
we'd been together for a few years
um winona ryder and uh
when we when
when we broke up
um
how do you fix that
i did go back and re rewrite my journal
to some degree i i took off the last two
letters
um
and had it say wino forever
um
just because i thought it was uh
i thought it was
again
through
pain
comes hum you
humor has to come in there so at some
point into the pain and that's how you
play it out in your
mind so
i
i have
i think sometimes abstractly uh
in that sense so i changed it to wino
forever
um
any other tattoos
um
well she was
she was very encouraging
um in in
in me getting
a tattoo of of
her of her name
or
whatever and uh
i waited a while and then i yes i did it
i
got a full tattoo of
her and it uh
ironically wasn't long after that that
the um
that everything started going sideways i
i was doing anything i could to
bring
a smile
to her face
as opposed to the frown
and then the onslaught of whatever
um
whatever problems she she she was
seeing or experiencing
um
i i
i even
liked i would try to wake her up
with laughter
um
you know singing stupid songs in her ear
while she
i
i generally just tried to keep
bringing her mood up
sometimes it worked
many times it didn't
um
but i i tried and i wanted to try
because as i said i didn't want to fail
and
at the time
not knowing
fully
not understanding fully
what i was
if you'll excuse the term
up against
um
i kept trying i kept trying but uh to no
avail whatsoever
okay it just got worse
mr depp i'd like to
fast forward a little bit to may of
2014.
um could you please tell the jury what
project you were working on in may of
2014
may of 2014.
may of 2014 i i'm i'm
there there were a number of films that
i made in succession i i can't
remember if that might have been
pirates
no i can't uh uh mordecai
or um
i don't remember what can you remind me
what may of 2014 film was
were you filming black mass in boston of
may yes okay yes excuse me yes
yes yes
oh yes i was uh
i was filming black a film called black
mass in in boston
and
mr did come with me
um
and i had
for the film i had to
there was there were very early calls to
work because i was i had a number of
prosthetics
uh blew to my face and
uh
blue contacts
um
so so that i could resemble
the the the actual it was based on the
true story of
james bulger james whitey bulger
and so i had a i had to go in quite
early to get
the prosthetics glued to my face and
all that and uh
work then you'd work you know the whole
day and then at the end of the night
uh
the uh
they would
remove the
the prosthetics which takes it
if it took three hours to put them on it
took about an hour to take them off you
know
so on top of a
what could be a anywhere between a 14 16
17 hour day of
work you know
what with the
application of the
of the makeup
and then the taking off of the
um applications
was miss heard staying with you in
boston during the entire time that you
were
making that film
yes
yes she was
and who from your staff was in boston
with you during that time
jerry judge
keenan wyatt
stephen duders
nathan holmes i believe
um
and i believe malcolm
connolly was there as well
so i would have
um
assistance
sound technician
um
security
i believe i believe that was it
mr depp we heard yesterday from mr wyatt
about a flight that you
and mr wyatt and miss heard were on from
boston
to la in march
excuse me may 2014 do you remember that
yes and could you please tell the jury
what you remember about that specific
flight
um
i remember as i was still shooting
filming black mass
um
before i
before i did black mass the film
my sister christy
and i were talking about
the
um the roxy codons that i had been
again you know that was the monkey on my
back uh
that
she came to me
she told me she'd read this book of dr
kipper's book and i read
uh
dr kipper's
book
a good majority of it and um i agreed
that i would
uh
do the detox i would
kick the uh
the opiates
was no time to do it before the film
so
when when the nurse
which was nurse debbie lloyd when she
came to boston
um
she she had asked me
what is your dosage what are you how
many of these are you taking per
day and
you know someone who had been under
uh
you know under the kind of lock and key
of of of a prescription
drug that is highly
highly addictive i mean with built-in
barbs that
this drug does not want you to stop
taking it
she asked me hi how many i took per day
or
my dosage
and
of course
as as
as any
uh
person who is addicted
and um
essentially a uh
a fool to the drug
and you know how important it is because
you have felt the sting when it doesn't
when you don't
have it
so
i'd agree to a degree to the
detox
and i'd
she asked me how many i took i told her
obviously
more
than i was taking
purely
because
when you're in that frame of mind
the one thing that you do not want to
a situation you don't want to find
yourself in
is having no access
to the thing that will make you
not high
it will make you it gets you you only
get better from it
if you start to get the
the the the
shakes and the tremors and the
uh the
you know you could feel this
traveling into your system your your
your
um
receptors
are out in
mass your receptors are demanding that
drug
if you if you don't give
the drug to the risk to the receptors
you're gonna you will start going into a
pretty nasty withdrawal and um
and it could uh
which
you know could uh
and has ended in you know sort of
seizures you could you can go into
pretty nasty seizures
so um i had told debbie lloyd
more
than was necessary
so that i could always have one or two
in my pocket on the just in case
so i didn't
find myself
you know on a plane or
anywhere without
one in my pocket to stop the
the inevitable
uh
body cramps and nausea and and and
stomach cramps and
seizure of the bones and shaking and
and also the it's quite an emotional
ride as well
so
yes i i i
before
the flight
amber
and her assistant
savannah
mcmillan wanted to be
picked up in
new
york and then have the plane fly to
boston to pick me up
to bring us back to los angeles
uh
um we had spoken the night before we had
argued the night before
um
she was
most
definitely
looking for a
she was
looking for a fight
actively searching for a way
to instigate
a fight
with me
um
and i had taken two
of these
um
opiates these oxycodones
um and i can i can tell you now
some of you may be very very well aware
of this opiates um
are extreme
downers
so
if you have
enough opiates in you
you will essentially go on
what's called the nod you'll just drop
into sleep
so
i've heard i've heard the words blackout
used and
[Music]
there's a grave difference between
a blackout
um from from from um
alcohol abuse
because that is a person who
has has has
ingested enough alcohol
um to render them
um
they can still behave and they can still
stand and talk and scream and yell and
cry and do whatever they do
and never remember a thing
and generally they're always embarrassed
by it
a blackout is a very very different
animal
to
um
the opiate taking you into dreamland
so
when i arrived on the plane
uh
i was
not feeling any pain
and
i knew that
she was
ready for
some kind of brawl and i
i sat on the plane drawing i was drawing
in my notebook
um
she would
verbally
heckle
hassle accuse
poke prod physically
you know
poke and prod psychologically
emotionally it just
and and and
finally
you know as was
my uh the one thing i learned
if you're gonna hide someplace from
somebody
go straight into the bathroom
so i walked back into the back of the
plane
um
i grabbed a pillow
and i went into the bathroom
locked the door
and laid down on the bathroom floor and
went to sleep
and that's where i remain for the rest
of the flight
how much if any alcohol had you had
before you got on the flight
i i honestly don't recall having any
alcohol i mean
maybe there was the sort of
glass of champagne
when you got on
on the plane or something like that the
initial
thing you know people order
glasses of wine people also tend to to
have a few drinks before a plane takes
off because some people don't like
the turbulence and this and that so it's
a little bit of a
liquid courage you know
um
but i i i certainly
after
after ingesting
two of the
reoxycodones
alcohol was not necessary
so i i i i can tell you now that i
was not drinking to excess certainly not
and if i had i've
probably
been in the bathroom
hugging porcelain as opposed to
sleeping on a pillow
who else was on that flight that you can
recall
um
i remember jerry judge was on the flight
savannah was on the flight
ms heard
kenan
wyatt
stephen deuters
i believe that's it
what do you recall happening after you
arrived back in la
go back to the same home together after
that flight
uh
no i don't believe no we didn't i don't
believe we did i think she
had decided if this is the time
pretty sure
i believe she had decided to check
herself into the chateau marmont
if the
there are so many of these
it's hard it's hard to sort of keep them
all straight
who would have paid for miss heard to
stay at the chateau mar mom
um
i'm
i would have paid for it
um
if she wanted to go to the shop to
marmont i wasn't going to let her
pay for it no matter the circumstances i
wasn't going to let her
pay for it because i knew that that
might
get expensive for for her
so
generally i uh
i would do
i would
take care of things of nature
and
why did miss heard tell you why she was
staying at the chateau marma
no
well i mean
she
was she was clearly
upset and she was
irate
and
i can't say that it was a bad idea for
her to stay at the chateau marmont at
that time i don't know why she went to
the chateau since she still had
her apartment on orange i believe
and the penthouse
because i i could have gone to sweet sir
but she went to the chat tomorrow
mr duff do you recall why you were
flying from boston to la in may 2014.
[Music]
i can't remember if it was a break from
the film
or if i had finished the film
and that was before we went
um
well before i was supposed to go to the
island to uh
to um
to detox from
from the
opiates i i think it's everybody's about
to switch gears so this is a good time
for a break all right ladies and we'll
go ahead and have our morning recess
please do not do any outside research
and don't talk to anybody about the case
and we'll see in 15 minutes okay thank
you
so
all right answer again since you're
still on the stand and not discuss your
testimony with anybody including your
attorneys okay
all right we'll come back at 11 35 all
right
ready for the jury okay
so
all right thank you
seated thank you all right your next
question
thank you
mr dub who's dr kipper
dr kipper is a um
uh he's he's been my doctor
since ever since i'd uh
met him in i believe it was that may of
2014 around around there in uh in boston
and why were you connected with dr
kipper
um
my sister christy
uh
knew of course that
i had had been
addicted to the to the
the opiates and
she was concerned
and she brought me his book
and
talked to me
heart to heart
and asked me if i would be willing to
go through the the detox and what was
your answer
yes
of course
and you mentioned um debbie lloyd can
you please explain to the jury who she
is oh
debbie
debbie lloyd is a
is a nurse
um who
my doctor dr kipper
had assigned to uh to my case to
to be the uh
um
to oversee
um the detox and
deliver
the meds the medications
to me
that would help with my uh
with the
the uh the effects of withdrawal that uh
that one goes through
the uh to to
essentially
try and knock you out
so that you don't go through
the
the nastiness of the
affair
did miss did miss lloyd stay on after
the detox process as your nurse
yes you did
and
when you were under dr kipper's care how
often
did you see miss lloyd
um on location
every day
um
yes on location every day
um
even when
after
um
a year or two i would
i was still seeing her
at least on a
bi-weekly basis from two to three times
a week
when did you start the detox process
that you mentioned
i know i know that it's
it
i believe it was around it was in august
july or august
of uh 2000
15 14 i cannot
remember the
year
14 i guess
and
where where did you do this detox
process
um
the detox process uh
um happened on
i have a place in the bahamas
um
i'm never comfortable saying this but
it's an island
it's a very strange thing to say
um but
i thought that that would be the best
place the most private
um place where there were no worries of
paparazzi or
any of that so it was it was a place
where i could literally be the only
place
where i can have
actual uh
anonymity
so i thought that would be the best
place to to do it
who came with you down to the island for
the detox
um
nurse debbie
lloyd
uh traveled
with me
on on the plane
um
uh
ms heard
and i i believe i believe that was i
believe that was it
um on the plane to to go to the island
for the detox
i was not bringing
security i was not bringing
assistance
in
in fact initially my
sister christie
was was going to
uh go there
um
to
help
ms lloyd and the doctor
through the detox which made perfect
sense since
that the whole thing had
been
born out of her
desire for me to
get clean um
so initially it was
supposed to be christy
coming
um
in place of misheard
i
there was a there was a great part of me
that was
uh very uncomfortable with ms heard
coming
along
for that
detox
because
as
as things could
fluctuate very rapidly
in our relationship
um
i was
i was wary that
that
those things would come up during
what needed to be
a very straight
detoxification of of of these substances
and i was
well aware that it was not going to be
pleasant i i was well aware that
that i was going to go through
quite a bit of uh
physical
changes
physical
um
yes i i i was i was afraid that it would
be
too much
for her
and i
also felt that
she might be too much
for
me at the time
so then why did miss hurt come down to
the island with you during the detox
process
um
she insisted
she switched places with
christy
could you please describe for the jury
mr deb what it feels like to go through
a detox from from opioids
um i would say the best
the best way to describe it is
it's it feels like you're
you're it feels like the inside of
you
the very inside of you
is trying to escape
the body
so
it's um
it becomes
obviously very physical
and so therefore
you'll go into
a withdrawal would
would mean that you're you would go into
you'd have immense cramps in your
stomach your muscles would seize
you
my body would shake
the pain is
like nothing i've ever
experienced before um
part of it was
the the best way to explain it for
example there was a situation
that
when we were on the island
and i was going through the detox
and it was
hitting pretty hard at that point
and ms heard had made a deal with
um
nurse
debbie and
dr kipper
to to stay
at their end of the island and that she
would administer the drugs to me it
administered the medications that that
that i needed to
not go into um
the
for lack of a better word the the these
intense
sharp
painful heebie-jeebies
and there was a moment
when i could feel my body starting to
tense and
i could feel the withdrawals coming on
and they
come on quick
and
they're not
they're not discreet
um
they go straight for
the jugular i mean
like i said when
when your receptors are in
full bloom and begging
for the
the the the substance the drug the the
the opiates that they that my body had
become used to the
these
um receptors that were being
fed by
um
there was a
moment when uh
it was it was coming on very fast and i
i
i
was sitting on the couch
in in the little house that we all saw
on the island
ms heard was at the
uh she was in the sort of kitchen area
and she was chopping
vegetables i remember
and
i i i think it was around 2 30 in the
afternoon and
the effects of the withdrawals were
really coming on
and i said to um
i said to miss her uh
i'm gonna need the meds
now
and she said uh
she looked at the clock and she said
it's not time
and i said no no you don't you don't
understand this is this is not about
clocks and watches and things
i'm going
i'm going into
the ship and it was visible
and um
i hate
i hate to have i hate saying this
and i hate to have to admit this
but that was uh
i believe that was
about the lowest point
in my life i was the lowest
i'd ever felt
as a
as a human being
because i had to say please
please
may i have the meds
because
it's really kicking in and
she was adamant
nope it's not time it's not time
so
in explaining
how these
these uh withdrawals
start to take over your body
when i was
begging
at that point for the meds i found that
i had
sort of rolled off the couch and i was
sitting on the floor
crying
i mean
tears streaming down my face begging
another human being to please
please give me
the meds that will take this away
and she would not
she was adamant that
nope
it's not time four o'clock
so the only thing that one can do in
that situation
is you have to trick the body
you have to
you have to manipulate your body
out away from those
well you have to trick the body to get
away from
the
receptors
so
the only thing that one can do is you go
straight to
[Music]
the shower
and um
you put it on scalding
water
and you stand underneath the scalding
shower
and
essentially you're burning
the top you know your skin is
burning from the heat of the water
and what that would do is it would trick
the nervous the nerves
away from the receptors because they had
now they had an immediate problem that
needed to be dealt with
the nerves so they so what it does is
the scalding shower
would
would would reverse
those
nerve endings and they would go up to
the
top of the skin
because
there was a problem there
so that's that's how you that's how i
was able to bypass
um those those withdrawal symptoms
at times it doesn't fully take them away
but but what it does is it tricks your
body into
into thinking that there's something
going horribly wrong on top
so it keeps them away from the receptors
um
and
after that
i had a conversation with
nurse debbie and with dr kipper
and i said
i don't believe
i told them that she had
denied me the meds when i was in need
and then i told him that i don't think
that this is going to work here anymore
i think we have to leave the island
and i need to be
we
she can't be
with me while i'm going through the rest
of this detoxification
so i thought i told him we should leave
the island
i told i asked
them
if
they if they understood what i was
doing and they did
so we went back to los angeles and then
i asked miss hurt if she would please
uh allow me
five days seven days whatever it took
to get out of to get done with finished
with the rest of this this this this
this horrific
detox and the pain
did miss her give you that time
she did reluctantly yes i was
i was immediately accused of
throwing her out
i was accused of
abandoning her
i was accused of
not appreciating all that she had done
to
get me to this point where i was which
was
kind of an interesting argument for me
uh i
begged her please
can i can i get a place
at the beverly hills hotel i'll get you
and your friends at bungalow at the
beverly hills hotel
where you can all stay together and have
a grand old flag you can have fun you
can do whatever you want and you don't
have to sit around mr
shakey
and
she wasn't happy about it but
i
it was very necessary so i she did
eventually
um leave for about five five days or so
and i
sat in a uh
after a few days i sat in a
a
a metal chair with one song on the
uh one song on a loop
that i could focus on the lyrics and the
the power of the song
um to help me get through it
and uh
even even once this the in
the deep
the the
effects
you know started to go away that is the
pain
i was still in this
something strange that happens
you feel
you feel electricity in your body
you you feel this electric
um
very foreign
and
you're just sitting sitting there like
going through it
and i didn't understand what the
electricity was
um until probably
and this lasted for
the electricity that that feeling lasted
for a month two months
and i finally realized at a certain
point what that electricity was
and um
i was feeling is that's what it was
i was
actually feeling
um without the aid of
the drug
without the aid of any drugs
i mean
i had i had refused
with dr kipper
and nurse debbie
and amber at the table before she left
for the
hotel with her friends i i had
refused to
continue taking
the phenobarbital
and the
lithium
because to me it was just another drug
in the way
it seemed like it was just another
hurdle to get over
and i would rather just get it
out of my system now
and and move forward
maybe i wouldn't have had the
electricity
maybe i wouldn't have felt as quickly
but um
i didn't i didn't want to take
phenobarbital and lithium
and seroquil and neurontin and all these
other things
uh and the worst of the two i believed
were were the were the uh
phenobarbital and the lithium
so i just i went through
that